fears of a red wave ramping up for
democrats the party already in a tizzy
over their terrible messaging but now
they've got another major problem
democrats are worried that kamala
harris's poor polling
could trickle down and cost them in the
midterms top allies of the vp reportedly
held a
crisis dinner and are blaming harris's
low approval ratings on
sexism in the media greg crisis dinner
that was the name of my metal band in
the 90s it's more like a new metal band
kind of faith no more ass crisis dinner
we didn't really work out that well
i love why was it called the crisis
dinner because she was cooking it
oh yeah look if it's urgent you don't
have a crisis dinner because no one's
gonna tell you you suck
to your face right she's gonna have her
friends over they're gonna go it's not
you it's not you it's not you
which is why she's made it this far and
it's but as much as i'd love to blame
kamala for everything it's not her fault
in fact
blaming her is actually the strategy
for i think for for biden's white house
and the democrats
to leave them off the hook so you don't
focus on the horrible messaging
the red wave is linked to the crime wave
enter the authoritarian wave
those are the two waves that matter she
she's not very good
but you know what you start focusing on
her you're letting all these other
idiots off the hook and
uh well that i'll stop there yeah greg's
talking about the real problems jesse i
call them satan's trinity
it's a high crime high inflation high
covet kamala harris has nothing to do
with that that is all
biden and biden alone and all of his
other cronies the smartest thing biden
did was make camel the tsar of the
border
now we're talking about kamala instead
of joe and that was
exactly what the strategy was so she's a
wounded animal obviously because the
border is in crisis
and so all the top women in the
democratic party went over to a swanky
soiree in georgetown
and then they leaked it they leaked that
this was a crisis this was urgent
and then they kind of characterized
themselves as this big group of
powerful operatives that are going to
save kamala hara
from the sexist media and it's also a
warning shot to the media
if you cover her negatively we're going
to smear you and attack you
as a sexist you know how she solves the
problem just do a good job on the border
solves everything no one's going to call
you names they'll say hey you did a good
job
did they let her go to the border would
biden company let kamala harris like
uh yes she was she was nearby she took
spirit
a couple of things here number one um i
i've worked a crisis before if you're
having a crisis you have more than one
dinner you have daily meetings
uh number one number two uh i looked at
the attendee list i know most of those
people one of those people are a former
colleague donna brazile
um and she would say we weren't serving
sandwiches
um and they were i think this was just a
group of people and one of the topics of
conversation
happen to be kamala harris and how they
can support the vice president um and i
think that's all that happened here in
this meeting it's worth pointing out
that the job numbers came out today and
we saw
a really good job numbers from this
president almost a million jobs added
it's the lowest
unemployment rate we've seen since the
beginning of the pandemic america is
coming back
get rid of the whole landlord's problem
then and
and i think beyond that i think over the
weekend we'll also see
some voting activity in the senate
finally after
almost now it's six five years on
infrastructure we desperately need some
new airports and some new bridges and
new roads
so more progress the president came to
washington him and kamala harris came to
washington and they said
they were going to try to bring
democrats and republicans together and
they're actually going to get it done
this weekend it looks like something
richard got his talking points yes well
done richard and they're right
and they're actually keep talking
they're true yeah keep talking about the
economy being on fire and then try to
explain why we need
addiction moratorium
why are you doing the eviction
moratorium and student loans today
as well delay and then also another five
five and a half trillion that they want
to spend
shannon just really quickly i to jesse's
point
you heard this actual messaging on the
view where joy behar said oh let's see
why
they're going after kamala harris oh
that's right she's a woman and she's
black i almost forgot
so that's a warning to any democrat who
who threatens her
tries to challenge her yes this is the
memo i talked about this last week that
we
literally got this memo from a number of
women's groups
before the election that said if you go
after her it will be considered sexism
and racism i mean they gave us the it
was a literal memo i printed out and
saved it i can send you a copy just
because
i i was like so this is so bizarre
they're telling us in advance that if
you criticize her at all this is what
it's going to be attributed to
but listen we know that the off-year
midterm elections for the party and
power of the white house is
usually not a good thing so they're
looking at having a tough year next year
even npr
said this is what the republicans are
going to use the border the economy and
crime
and they're going to have plenty of
stuff to talk about were you listening
to npr i was
reading an article i think it's
important to stay fully informed
uh but listen they also have others out
there that are causing trouble for them
with a possible red wave which are
like congresswoman corey bush this week
i mean that's a headache for the
democrats to say no we don't really mean
to fund the police and she's like oh yes
i mean to fund the police so
they have multiple friends to worry
about yeah kamala harris can have an
easy weekend she'd just go
cory bush straight up hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else